the jurogan experience i can start
releasing
[ __ ] from my archives even like past
lance performances
you could hear jeff scott laughing in
the corner and stuff jeff's girl she's
so sad
yeah i miss him i miss him too i miss
him so much that made me so sad
and it hit me coming by surprise because
you don't realize you've been this is
this person has been a part of your life
for so long because you just seem like
you're doing a set at the comedy store i
have a different situation because i've
been with jeff since 94.
94.95 i think he came around and then
you know we were
i hadn't seen him for so long and then
um
when i came back to the store and in
2014 he was like one of the first people
i saw
and uh he had
he was just always there man he was he
was a sweet guy
and always hugging everybody
when i found out he died one of the
first things i felt like was like i
don't think he would have died if it
wasn't for this [ __ ] pandemic
i thought i felt like
i think it hit a lot of us he was
[ __ ]
he was such a part of the store he was
the one of the biggest parts of store
without being a comic
yeah without being a guy who actually
got on stage he was one of the biggest
parts of the store
and that felt like 10 months of him
having no connection you know that was
everything he was there every night man
yeah i i hugged that guy every time i
saw him
he he was like a performer without being
a performer
like obviously he did the piano but he
had such great comedy instincts having
done performing in his past and such
because you've been the clubs before and
they're sound guys and they're like
yeah they're not really yeah they're not
but this guy he was like jazz man
yeah he was he was a performer he was a
performer there had been times when i
was doing lance or whatever
and he would just like turn on a certain
song and it was never disruptive it was
always
additive and to think about not having
that
when we go back and for it to happen
during all this too where you can't even
like properly process what what
there was a zoom there was a zoom room
where people could pop in and kind of
like talk about jeff and have all these
jeff stories and like i had to hop in
there and
it was so many people there's so many
great comics big comics too
like the zoom room was like 100 people
just
it was it was great to at least have
that so it sucked to have something that
seismic happen
in a vacuum there was a ritual that i
would do not a ritual just like a
thing that i would always do pull into
the parking lot say hi to everybody hug
all the people i saw
and go to the back smoking area and i'd
always find jeff scott getting high
always yeah i get high with him i give
him a big hug
and i go how am i how many more people
before i go on and he'd be like well you
know jeff frost is on stage now he got
like
two more people and then you go okay and
then i'll go
he was like he was he was a part of the
foundation
he was he was he was so important man
when he was
gone i was like oh mike no
he hurt as much as brody it
hurt as much as anybody i i agree and it
creeps up on you you don't realize
every set that i've done at the comedy
store he's he's been a part of
yeah and what i loved about jeff is
he he was willing to play
and play is such a big part sometimes
stand up you can be so self serious and
think that you're
changing the world and there is that but
sometimes it's fun to just have
fun and i would get these hair brained
ideas of like oh
here's a music queue let's do this and
he would be chomping at the bit
because most comics just play up play
off right
but if i'm like i need him to play some
piano or i need him to play this song
he kind of lit up because it was like a
mini yeah musical or something right
right and and like seeing his spark
because a lot of times i'll go to a city
and i'm like i have these sound cues and
you can see them kind of like roll their
eyes or like uh
it's more work but jeff was more than
down
and he was embedded in the dna of the
comedy store
he was there for how long 20 years 25
years more yeah i think he was 26 years
when he died
and he's the unofficial archivist of
of the comedy story because that place
is notorious for
no cameras no filming but sometimes he
would have his flip cam
from he also remember everything yeah he
had an amazing memory
but he has this amazing catalog of
magical moments at that place that now
i think the store is working with the
family and stuff to try to retrieve
especially in a pandemic if you notice
like the comedy store's instagram
what's unfortunate is that i love that
place you love that place
it's such a magic but it's it's this
black box
no one knows the magic that happened
there well we know
and we know that the fans know the
people that there was a lot of people
that would go there
get there get that band should i get it
off get with that top band too
you got another band taking all the
clothes off they had two bands on i
understand
the double band thing he is
the the people that would go there a lot
they knew
that was one of the beautiful things is
like i ran into this dude
um before uh everything locked down
and he was talking to me about a very
specific bit and he was like i i just
love how that bit is changed
you know you started out this way yeah
and then i could see that you saw that
there was like a problem with it that
way and then
you snuck it in the back door in another
way and then it started to pop
i love those fans yeah the hardcore ones
who like can see the process
like guys who love jazz who don't play
any musical instruments
most people aren't like that yeah but
i've noticed there's
there's two store fans there's two
audiences
there's the physical audience the people
who go there in la
and like like that guy can see the
nuance
and then there's the online audience you
don't realize how big the store is just
sort of culturally
and throughout the country they can't go
to the store every day so they don't
know
and it's almost like the online version
is is their version of the store catch
new episodes of the joe rogan experience
for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre in the background
while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify
app go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience